meine damen und herren begrüßt sie
gemeinsam mit mir den soeben aus kanada
nach köln eingeflogenen model manager
international fashion icon und gntm
reactor lucius bord zu lassen
[Musik]
die fresse du lachen herzlich willkommen
hier heute zum zweiten teil von meiner
reaktion auf die 28 kandidatinnen von
germany's next topmodel 2020 ich habe
mich wieder in schale geworfen mit einem
neuen gucci t shirt einigen tagen habe
ich hier auf meinem kanal ja schon auf
14 der 28 gravis ex-topmodel 2020
kandidatinnen reagiert und ich würde
sagen wir machen jetzt direkt weiter bei
ihr hier
das ist die liebe bianca nicht zu
verwechseln mit sie hat hier auch in
style verpasst bekommen wo ich mir
einfach denke wir wissen allerdings
würde ich sagen konnte war ein bisschen
runter bei der bianca sie ist 18 jahre
alte schülerin und kommt aus aachen ihk
schülerin und strebt derzeit ihr abitur
an in ihrer freizeit begeistert sie ihre
community als micro in pflanzen oft
wissen ist denn ein mikro influenza
ist nicht ein influenza in flames
schauen wir uns mal dass
vorstellungsvideo von der lieben bianca
an ich würde nicht mit einer marke
zusammenarbeiten wollen
wie hält sie bitte das mikro ich würde
nicht mit einer marke zusammenarbeiten
wollen dir viel bekanntes tierversuche
zu machen nicht mit einer marke zwar
einmal war dafür bekannt ist
tierversuche zu machen
ja meine damen und herren ich würde
allerdings sagen wir machen direkt
weiter mit der liliana das ist sie hier
nämlich ich weiß nicht was die sich alle
bei den wimpern gedacht haben
sieht so ein bisschen aus wie diese
teile die es früher als armband gab die
man so abbeißen konnte wisst ihr das
hier ist auf jeden fall die liliana
wertvoll ein bisschen mehr darunter
klicken auch hier auf mehr anzeigen sie
ist 23 jahre alt studentin aus kassel
und zwar studiert siege
grundschullehramt wow
stell mal vor du guckst gntm und dann
kommt so eine referendarin rein und das
ist einfach scheißegal angefangen habe
ich mit ballett habt dann mit 67 jahren
angefangen hip hop tanzen mit 14 jahren
hatte ich dann meine erste eigene
tanzgruppe
ich tanze seit dem ich ein embryo pin
des tödlichen dance battle mit dieser
person das ist sie lieber alina vom stil
her würde ich sagen komplett normal
einfach herunter alina studenten
schlussspurt alina studierte
medienwissenschaften möchte jedoch
lieber die laufstege dieser welt erobern
sie ist ein ehrlicher und sehr
ehrgeiziger mensch der genau weiß was er
will ihr großes vorbild ist ihre mutter
die in ihren augen stark und unabhängig
ist und den schönsten charakter hat und
das ist süß alias freunde des
profifußballs dem begriff spielerfrau
nicht so gerne habe ich das gefühl dass
man irgendwie immer unter einem teppich
gekehrt wird mit vielen blonde dummchen
na gut selbst bloß halt sie ist halt
eine spielerfrau also klar dieser
begriff spielerfrau hat immer so einen
negativen beigeschmack dass man sich
denkt ja die sehen nur gut aus und die
können gar nichts deswegen ich finds gut
auf jeden fall dass die
medienwissenschaften studiert und ich
bleib dabei eine spielerfrau weil sie in
der spielerfrau ist also klar ihr freude
ist profi fußballer in sizilien
inwiefern man profifußball mit ziel
zusammenbringen kann es mir auch noch
geraten rätsel aber ich finde auf jeden
fall stark dass sie auf eigenen beinen
stehen will ihr eigenes geld verdienen
will und wir machen weiter mit den
ersten person und zwar ist das die liebe
johanna hier ich sage immer diesen alle
lieb die werber das ist die liebe satz
klar die liebe johanna die liebe
fritz-peter 1 allgemein mal ganz kurz
bevor die hilfe der johanna weitermachen
möchte ich das jetzt wieder sagen nichts
davon ist böse gemeint ich hab das zum
letzten video ziemlich häufig gesagt und
mich ziemlich häufig gerechtfertigt
danke übrigens dass der erste teil wie
ich auf germany's next topmodel
-kandidatinnen reagiere mega gut bei
euch angekommen ist also die bewertungen
sind irgendwie bei 90,5 das hat schon
fast eine millionen aufrufe
ja abnehmer einer liebe freunde ich
wollte auf jeden fall nur sagen dass er
bitte alle aussagen hier ironisch zu
verstehen sind mit humor zu verstehen
sie mich möchte ich niemanden irgendwie
persönlich schikanieren oder angreifen
oder irgendwas allerdings machen wir
weil damit der johanna sie ist angehende
studentin sie findet es gut dass
heutzutage auch kurvige frauen in der
modelwelt erfolg haben und
außergewöhnliche typen gefragt sind dann
stimmt das
da kriegt der in der woche also ich habe
bisher schon hilft macht aber auch
überhaupt nicht schlimm ist als ich
fühle mich wohl in meinem körper also
das würde ich jetzt soll ich ein score
ich bezeichne das ist auf jeden fall die
nächste kandidatin namens marie hat auf
jeden fall leicht ein pink tick das
sieht man schon marias 19 jahre waren
die da früher auch schon immer alles so
jung ja ja gut okay in meinem ersten
teil hat mir eine 16 jährige marie eve
19 jahre und studiert in london in der
falten und mondo sprachen lernen in der
schule haben sie mich immer der
panikmacher genannt weil ich vor ort
kurz arbeiten oder so immer so die
nervöse aufgeregt überall immer gesagt
habe gehört schaffen wir das und wisst
ihr was ich gerade viel erstaunlicher
finde unter dem video steht dieser
kommentar marie doppelpunkt ich bin
süchtig nach karotten hey du bist aber
liebe schreibt ich mal wieder kurz in
einem satz das buch bleibt das ist die
nächste kandidatin mit dem namen
charlotte im gesicht sieht sie auf jeden
fall leicht gemacht aus da sieht das ein
bisschen wenn die wangen aufgespritzt
und auch die lippen so ein bisschen als
ist nichts negatives man kann ja
verändern am körper was man möchte aber
man sieht hier auf jeden fall schon
stark sie ist ein spiritueller und sehr
empathischer mensch der schwingungen
wahrnehmen kann ich macht aus
dass ich sehr spirituell bin das ist auf
jeden fall die liebe julia f sie hat
hier irgendwie so blitzer auf der
kopfhaut und zwei triangeln in den ohren
hängen und hat auch so einen schwarzen
müllsack an und ein t shirt was in den
farben gefallen der style hier wieder
zeigen soll allerdings ist die julia 20
jahre alt und kommt aus schweinfurt
julia ihre ausbildung zur
einzelhandelskauffrau auf eis gelegt
perücken habe ich sieben stück und ich
liebe es auf meine haarfarbe zu wechseln
machen
rosen ist das ja schon einmal vor ich
gehe morgen sind baden denken okay bin
ich heute bin ich heute braun wenn ich
heute rosa hab ich habe vielleicht gar
keine haare machen wir weiter mit der
lieben larissa die hier auf jeden fall
ein bisschen mehr haut zeigt als die
anderen kandidatinnen
sie ist 19 jahre alt und abiturienten
aus mörfelden-walldorf gesundheit heidi
erst mal alles gute zur hochzeit ich
hätte richtig bock dich kennenzulernen
ich würde gerne germany's next topmodel
werden
ich hätte da richtig bock darauf die
larissa muss ich wirklich sagen wirkt
wie ein sehr sehr sehr sehr
sympathischer mensch ich glaube der wird
in der voll der der larissa wer kennt
ihn nicht auf larissa wird so ein
bisschen publikumsliebling in der neuen
staffel gntm allerdings machen wir hier
mit der julia weiter
die im vergleich zum marissa ihrem arm
abgeschnitten hat unter anderem julia
ist mit ihren 17 jahren das küken unter
den top model anwärterinnen wir haben
noch eine 16 jährige aber die haben sie
anscheinend komplett vergessen
ihre eltern stammen aus polen daher
spricht sie auch polnisch auch
wahnsinnig dass die springer brasilianer
allerdings machen wir weiter mit der
sarah die ist 20 zahnarzt assistent und
kommt aus vorau das ist der ort liegt
vor wo man sich mal weh tut hat
ich bin ein sehr humorvoller mensch
sympathisch abenteuerlustiger es ist so
richtig wie beim vorstellungsgespräch
aber gut meine lieben freunde kommen
jetzt auch schon zu den vier letzten
kandidatinnen der diesjährigen staffel
gntm es ist einmal die pienaar
das ist ein interessanter name ich würde
mal sagen die kommt aus spanien
wie nah ist steuerfachangestellte und
hat türkische wo mein gott
ich habe angst zu versagen bei germany's
next topmodel das ist meine größte angst
meine größte angst ist dass menschen
sterben die mir nahestehen
aber das ist auch okay wie vivian ist
die drittletzte kandidatinnen uns heute
anschauen und zwar ist sie 21 jahre alte
und make up artistin außerdem münchen
und ein sehr humorvoller mensch
verbringt viel zeit in der natur liest
bücher macht gerne fotoshootings ja
wahnsinn verdacht hat video so über sie
denkt als model machen ich bin für meine
langen beine erstmal aus aber ansonsten
dass jetzt die vorletzte kandidatin fürs
heutige video meine lieben freunde ist
die liebe maureen die hat hier so eine
art skibrille auf und die jacke ist
irgendwie auch ein bisschen zu kurz
ich bin froh weil ich von einem spieler
das nicht
[Musik]
und das hier ist die letzte kandidatin
die wir uns anschauen werden das ist die
liebe laura sie sieht aus wie ein
komplett normales mädchen aber gut
schauen uns hier unten mal den text über
die liebe laura an und zwar sie 19 jahre
und studentin aus düsseldorf sie es
angehende studenten und konnte schon als
kind erste model erfahrungen bei
shootings sammeln sie beschreibt sich
als selbstbewusst und fühlt sich vor der
kamera pudelwohl hammer ihr
lieblingsessen sind trüffel nudeln okay
wir würden uns gut verstehen ich bin da
rein ich bin 19 jahre alt kam aus
düsseldorf und ich werde hoffentlich
germany's next topmodel 2020
man merkt irgendwie schon so gefüllt
meine eigene reitbahn an der stelle ich
das heute wieder jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
der zweite teil luca reagiert auf die
germany's next topmodel 2020
kandidatinnen gefallen hat dann das
unbedingt einen daumen unter dem video
[Applaus]
schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare von
welcher person ihr denkt dass sie das
zeug hätte germany's next topmodel 2020
zu werden ich ich ich ich werde
[Musik]